>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
THERE IS A NEW CONGRESS HERE
IN WASHINGTON.
BUT THE GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN
CONTINUES AS BEFORE.
THE STALEMATE OVER THE BORDER
WALL FUNDING ENTERED THE THIRD
WEEK.
EACH SIDE BETTING THE OTHER
WILL GIVE IN FIRST.
NEGOTIATIONS CONTINUE AT THE
WHITE HOUSE TODAY BUT
APPARENTLY THEY BORE NO FRUIT.
BECAUSE AFTERWARDS THE
PRESIDENT EMERGED TO SAY THE
SITUATION ON THE SOUTHERN
BORDER IS SO GRAVE HE MAY BE
FORCED TO BUILD A WALL WITHOUT
CONGRESSIONAL APPROVAL.
>> HAVE YOU CONSIDERED USING
EMERGENCY POWERS TO GRANT
YOURSELF AUTHORITY TO BUILD
THIS WALL WITHOUT
CONGRESSIONAL APPROVAL?
AND SECOND --
>> YES, I HAVE.
>> YOU HAVE?
>> President Trump: I HAVE.
I CAN DO IT IF I WANT.
>> SO YOU DON'T NEED
CONGRESSIONAL APPROVAL?
>> President Trump: NO.
WE CAN CALL A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY BECAUSE OF THE
SECURITY OF THE COUNTRY.
ABSOLUTELY.
NO WE CAN DO IT.
I HAVEN'T DONE IT.
I MAY DO IT.
BUT WE CAN CALL A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY AND BUILD IT
QUICKLY.
>> Tucker: DEMOCRATS CALL
THAT EXTREMISM.
WHO ARE EXTREME?
THE ONE WHO REFUSE TO DEFEND
THEIR COUNTRY.
THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE SAID
THEY WILL NEVER ALLOCATE A
SINGLE TAX DOLLAR TO BUILD A
BORDER WALL.
NOT BECAUSE IT'S TOO
EXPENSIVE, THESE ARE THE
DEMOCRATS.
BUT A WALL WOULD VIOLATE A
PREVIOUSLY UNKNOWN AND NEVER
EXPLAINED MORAL CODE.
WATCH.
>> THE FACT IS A WALL IS AN
IMMORALITY.
IT'S NOT WHO WE ARE AS A
NATION.
IT'S AN OLD WAY OF THINKING.
>> Tucker: IT'S TEMPTING TO
ASSUME THAT THE SPEAKER
MISSPOKEN THERE.
BUT IT'S HARDLY THE FIRST TIME
SHE SAID IT.
IMMORAL.
IMMORALITY.
SHE USED THE WORDS REPEATEDLY.
DEMOCRAT IS THE HIGHEST
RANKING DEMOCRAT IN THE UNITED
STATES.
THE LEADER OF HER PARTY.
SO WE SHOULD NOT BLOW IT OFF.
WE SHOULD TAKE IT SERIOUSLY.
AS A MATTER OF POLICY,
DEMOCRATS BELIEVE A BORDER
WALL IS IMMORAL.
THAT RAISES THE QUESTION WHAT
DO THEY CONSIDER MORAL?
WELL, AMERICAN TROOPS STUCK
FOREVER IN SYRIA FOR ONE
THING.
THAT IS JUST FINE.
SEX-SELECTIVE ABORTIONS PAID
FOR WITH THE TAX DOLLARS.
CAN'T GET MORE MORAL THAN
THAT.
AN TIFF FA IN -- AND ANTIFA IN
THE STREET IS ALL PERFECTLY
MORAL.
WALLS CAN BE MORAL IN THE
RIGHT CIRCUMSTANCES BUT CAN'T
PROTECT AMERICA.
THEY SIGNED OFF FOR BORDERS IN
ISRAEL, EGYPT AND JORDAN.
NO PROBLEM.
BUT HERE ON BEHALF OF OUR OWN
PEOPLE NO.
AMERICANS DON'T DESERVE THAT.
THEY ARE IMMORAL FOR ASKING.
THOSE ARE THE PARAMETERS TO
THE MORALITY.
WHAT RELIGION IS THIS EXACTLY?
WE ARE JOINED BY AN ATTORNEY,
RADIO HOST, FORMER AIDE TO
CHUCK SCHUMER AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
IF YOU WOULD, I THINK WE
TALKED ABOUT THIS BEFORE.
NANCY PELOSI REPEATEDLY CALLED
THE WALL IMMORAL.
AT FIRST I THOUGHT SHE TALKS A
LOT AND SOMETIMES YOU
MISSPEAK.
I KNOW THE FEELING.
BUT NOW SHE IS SAYING
SOMETHING AS THE LEADER
OFFICIALLY OF THE PARTY.
SO THE DEMOCRATS BELIEVE
BORDER WALLS ARE IMMORAL.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> I DON'T THINK SHE MEANS IT
IN THE GOOD VERSUS EVIL TYPE
OF MORALITY.
BUT RATHER THIS IS A WASTE OF
MONEY SINCE A LADDER AND A
ROPE CAN BEAT A WALL.
>> Tucker: LET ME INTERRUPT
YOU.
WHAT OTHER SENSE OF IMMORAL IS
THERE?
BY DEFINITION IMMORAL
DESCRIBES SOMETHING NOT MORAL.
IN THE SCHEME OF MORALITY, A
RELIGIOUS PRECEPT.
MA DOES IT MEAN?
HOW IS THE WALL IMMORAL?
>> LOOK.
I DON'T THINK SHE MEANS IT IN
A GOOD VERSUS EVIL RELIGIOUS
WAY.
>> Tucker: WHAT OTHER WAY IS
THERE?
>> IT'S STUPID THING TO BUILD
WHEN A GUY WITH A LADDER AND
FOOT TALL AND ROPE TO GET ON
THE OTHER SIDE COULD BEAT IT.
AND FRANKLY TO BORROW THE
N.R.A.'S ARGUMENT, THOUGH, IF
WE PUT A WALL UP TO BLOCK OUT
ILLEGAL -- PEOPLE WHO COME
HERE TO WANT TO HARM US.
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO COME HERE
LEGALLY ARE THE ONLY ONES
STOPPED BY THE WALL.
PEOPLE COMING HERE ILLEGALLY
WILL FIGURE OUT A WAY AROUND
IT LIKE THEY FIGURE OUT A WAY
TO GET GUNS.
>> Tucker: SO THEY WILL GET
THEIR OWN -- I THINK I'M
FOLLOWING YOU.
THEY WILL GET THEIR OWN WALL
AND BUY A WALL ON THE BLACK
MARKET AND BRING THE WALL TO
OUR WALL AND BEAT IT?
IS THAT CONTINUING THE
METAPHOR?
>> LAW ABIDING PEOPLE ARE
STOPPED BY THE WALL BUT PEOPLE
WHO WISH TO BREAK OUR LAWS
WILL AVOID THE WALL.
THAT IS THE RIGHT ARGUMENT FOR
EVERYTHING --
>> Tucker: I'M TRYING TO --
>> IT SHOULD BE ACCEPTED HERE,
TOO.
>> Tucker: I'M TRYING TO
TAKE YOU SERIOUSLY.
IS THAT ALSO TRUE IN PRISON
SURROUNDED BY LAWS?
LAWS MEANT TO KEEP LAWBREAKERS
IN?
DO THEY NOT WORK?
>> A PRISON IS A COUPLE OF
ACRES.
YOU HAVE CENTURY POINT TO
MONITOR THE WALL.
THE PRESIDENT IS TALKING ABOUT
THOUSANDS OF MILES OF WALL.
DO WE HAVE CENTURIES EVERY
HUNDRED FEET TO WATCH THE
WALL?
WE WOULD BE BETTER OFF WITH
THE MODERN TECHNOLOGY AND USE
THE DRONES AND OTHER THINGS TO
MONITOR THE BORDER AND MAKE
SURE IT'S BACKED UP BY THE
APPROPRIATE BORDER PATROL.
>> Tucker: I'M TRYING TO BE
REASONABLE.
>> IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
>> Tucker: WE BOTH KNOW YOU
ARE IN FAVOR OF MORE PEOPLE
COMING HERE ILLEGALLY AND I'M
NOT.
THAT IS THE ACTUAL DEBATE.
>> I'M NOT.
I'M NOT IN FAVOR OF ANYBODY
COMING HERE ILLEGALLY.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE WE ARE
NOT.
I WANT TO DRILL DOWN A LITTLE
BIT ON THE IDEA OF MORALITY.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT.
THE LEADER OF A POLITICAL
PARTY CALLS THE OTHER SIDE
IMMORAL IS NOT A SMALL THING.
THE SAME DAY SHE SAID THAT SHE
PUSHED TO ALLOW TAXPAYER
DOLLARS FROM THE UNITED STATES
TO GO ABROAD TO FUND ABORTIONS
IN LATIN AMERICA, AMONG OTHER
PLACES.
SO YOU ARE SAYING IT'S IMMORAL
TO KEEP LATIN AMERICA OUT WITH
A WALL BUT IS NOT IMMORAL TO
PAY FOR LATIN AMERICAN
ABORTIONS?
THAT IS WHAT NANCY PELOSI IS
SAYING.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
>> WE WOULD NEED A COUPLE OF
HOURS TO DISCUSS THE MOR RALTY
OF ACTION -- MORALITY OF THE
ACTION OF CHOICE.
I'M PRO CHOICE.
I WON'T PUSH --
>> Tucker: IS IT IMMORAL TO
PAY FOR ABORTIONS IN OTHER
COUNTRIES?
>> TAX DOLLARS DO NOT PAY FOR
ABORTIONS IN OTHER COUNTRIES.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE TRYING
TO CHANGE THAT.
>> SO IT WILL NEVER GO THAT
WAY.
TO DEBATE IF IT'S MORAL OR
IMMORAL IS A LORG
CONVERSATION.
>> Tucker: IT'S NOT.
>> I AM NOT ASKING YOU TO
CONDUCT THEOLOGY HERE.
I'M ASKING FOR YOUR VIEW.
TAXPAYER MONEY FOR
SEX-SELECTED ABORTION, WHICH
PELOSI IS FOR, OR BUILDING A
WALL?
WHICH IS IMMORAL?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE THAT SHE IS
FOR SEX-SELECTIVE ABORTIONS.
>> Tucker: SHE IS.
SHE IS.
>> THAT IS AN OVERREACH OF
WHAT SHE IS FOR.
>> Tucker: IN FACT SHE IS.
>> THE MORE MORAL USE OF THE
FUNDING FOR THE WALL IS TO FIX
BRIDGES AND ROADS CRUMBLING IN
THE COUNTRY THAT KNEAD REPAIR
AND SPEND A COUPLE OF BUCKS ON
RING DOORBELLS FOR THE BORDER
SECURITY IF YOU'RE WORRIED
ABOUT IT.
IT'S NOT AS BIG OF A PROBLEM.
WHAT IS IMMORAL IS THE
PRESIDENT MAKING A PROBLEM
THAT DOESN'T EXIST.
>> Tucker: REALLY QUICK.
AT THE SAME TAME AGAIN THAT
SHE WAS PUSHING AGAINST
AMERICAN'S ABILITY TO DEFEND
ITSELF AND THE BORDERS AND FOR
MORE TAXPAYER FUNDED ABORTIONS
IN OTHER COUNTRY E IS PUSHING
FOR MORE FOREIGN AID FOR
COUNTRIES SOME OF WHICH WOULD
GO TO BORDER SECURITY.
WE FUNDED WITH HER APPROVAL
BORDER SECURITY AND WALLS IN A
BUNCH OF OTHER COUNTRIES.
WHY WERE THOSE NOT IMMORAL BUT
OUR WALL IS IMMORAL?
>> WELL, WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THE ISRAELI WALL, AND OTHER
COUNTRIES THAT HAVE THE WALLS
LIKE THAT, THEY ARE IN A
CONSTANT STATE OF THE WAR WITH
THE NEIGHBOR.
WE ARE NOT IN A STATE OF WAR
WITH MEXICO.
>> Tucker: NOT TRUE.
>> WE ARE NOT HAVING A TRY
ANALYSIS OF THE BORDER --
CRISIS OF THE BORDER.
PEOPLE DON'T LOB BOMBS FROM
THE COUNTRY FROM MEXICO.
THEY ARE THE BIGGEST TRADING
PARTNER.
>> Tucker: I UNDERSTAND
THAT.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF BARRIERS
IN ISRAEL, SOME OF THEM ARE
DESIGNED TO KEEP TERRORISTS
FROM COMING IN.
I DON'T THINK ANYONE QUESTION
THE RIGHT TO DO THAT.
GOOD FOR THEM.
BUT THERE IS ALSO A BORDER ON
THE SOUTHERN BORDER OF EGYPT
DESIGNED TO KEEP IMMIGRANTS
FROM AFRICA OUT OF THEIR
COUNTRY.
I THINK IT'S ISRAEL'S RIGHT TO
BUILD THE WALL.
I WOULDN'T CONTEST THAT.
I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
IT.
BUT NANCY PELOSI DOESN'T HAVE
A PROBLEM WITH IT EITHER.
THAT WALL IS NOT IMMORAL.
OUR WALL IS IMMORAL.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT.
WHAT IS THE ANSWER?
>> YOU KNOW, WE ARE A NATION
OF.
I -- OF IMMIGRANTS.
IT MAKES US GREAT AND GIVES US
COMPETITIVE EDGE WITH THE REST
OF THE WORLD.
IF THE PRESIDENT AND THE PARTY
WANT TO CHANGE THAT, THAT IS
WHAT THEY SHOULD TALK ABOUT.
BUT WHAT THEY ARE DOING
DEMAGOGUING ABOUT A INVISIBLE
THREAT THAT DOES NOT EXIST AT
THE BORDERMENT.
IT'S TIME TO STOP THAT AND
HAVE A DISCUSSION ABOUT
SECURITY.
>> Tucker: HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE HERE ILLEGALLY IN THE
UNITED STATES?
DO YOU KNOW?
>> I WOULD THINK OVER 10
MILLION.
10 TO 14 MILLION.
>> Tucker: TRY OVER 20.
THIS IS AN ESTIMATE FROM THE
IVY LEAGUE RESEARCHERS.
DOES IT SEEM LIKE A LOT.
DOES IT SEEM LIKE THE CURRENT
BORDER SECURITY IS WORKING?
>> IT SEEMS LIKE A LOT.
IT SEEMS LIKE A LOT.
90% OF THOSE PEOPLE, TUCKER,
DID NOT CROSS THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
>> HOW DO YOU KNOW THAT?
>> THEY MAY HAVE COME HIRE ON
A PLANE OR A BOAT.
>> YOU DON'T KNOW THAT.
YOU DON'T KNOW HOW MANY ARE
HERE.
HOW DO YOU KNOW HOW THEY GOT
HERE?
>> I WASN'T PREPARED FOR THAT
QUESTION.
BUT EVERY IVY LEAGUE STUDY I
HAVE READ SHOWS EVERY IVY
LEAGUE STUDY I READ ABOUT THE
TOPIC SAYS THE SAME THING.
MOST PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE
ILLEGALLY OVERSTAYED THEIR
VISAS.
BUILDING A WALL AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER IS NOT GOING
TO CHANGE THAT.
IT'S A WASTE OF MONEY.
>> Tucker: WE ARE JUST
GUESSING THAT IT'S NOT GOING